you're in the dating circle now what do
you look for like when you're thinking
about
what are your like your top things
you're talking about sense of humor when
it comes to women like what what do you
want in a woman right now well well
obviously first and foremost is going to
be obviously you have to be physically
attracted i mean that's just right up
the jump some of that that's appealing
to you that you could see yours you know
go out have drinks but i'm right off the
jump personality is
paramount i like i'm being dead serious
i don't care like masters or you know
where she's working everybody's
everybody's hustling and doing their
things especially in this in this area
just somebody that i could just talk to
for more than five minutes that i'm just
i'm not like oh god i gotta get the see
but you're funny you're really funny so
do they have to be as funny as you no no
no i i i swear to god i had this
conversation yesterday if they get me
and they can laugh at what i'm talking
about that to me is a turn-on it's weird
i'm like because i got you but then and
then
actually the girl that i was kind of
talking to it triggered her to be funny
back to me i was like and then i was
like oh [ __ ] yeah you have it too you're
not a comedian but it's that i'm telling
you it's just that i don't know what it
is did you like that better what's up
did you like that better she was funny
with it i like i liked it better because
yo when she was witty i was like oh my
oh wow okay yeah so it's almost like a
fun it's not a competition it's just
like yo it's just saying [ __ ] and it's
funny because she'd say something in the
other room and i'd be like did you like
laughing out like did she just say that
like that's [ __ ] hilarious like i
love it but um and obviously you know
has i want a girl to have you know a
future you know she wants to beat you
know somebody she's you know has a you
know a job and all that stuff but
personality to me looks and personality
boom and when you mean looks do you like
would you would you rather have say
there's two women and you would rate one
looks wise as a 10 and one is an eight
but the eight has like a really bomb
awesome personality is that worthless
even like honestly i'm in my 40s set a
seven and i'm not i'm not a rating guy
but like a seven with a dual personality
yeah
i'm not i'm not a rating guy but like a
seven with the dope personality yeah
boom because the ten that's a that's
hard [ __ ] being with the ten it's
like oh i gotta [ __ ] fight everybody
i'm oh and i'm not a jealous guy but i
am a [ __ ] jealous guy
you can't leave a 10 to go to the market
i'm like no i'm coming
like it's right there i'm like i don't
give a [ __ ] i'm not yeah i'm not dealing
also no guarantee at 10's gonna be have
a personality that's the bottom line a
lot of the time and you got a hot empty
vase yeah that's like what are you doing
with that exactly and a lot of the times
i'm not gonna front the tens aren't
really that they don't have a lot of
personality because yo they don't need
it because guys are just trying to
holler at them and i'm saying they'll
give you the money they'll they'll take
care of you i want a girl with a little
if you're yo once you start dipping down
to like the sixes and fives and [ __ ] you
better bring some [ __ ] to the table
because there ain't nobody buying you
[ __ ] ain't nobody you know i mean your
dad better have a good job you know i
mean your dad better have a good job
something's gonna be going on yeah but
yeah i'm telling you right now
personality humor bumps up attraction to
me big time especially especially that
i'm a comedian that it's such a such a
turn-on what do you think about these
girls that go on these shows or the guys
is it all fame it's a bachelorette
it's all it's all those real world all
those shows it's like bro they just want
to get on like the jerseys
yeah the jersey shore like if you think
about it we laughed at we laughed at
those [ __ ] people we like vinnie and
this i know jenny
i i met him at the at the laugh factory
in l.a the situation is a [ __ ] a-list
celebrity do you understand and then
whenever that dude walks into a
restaurant in l.a it's oh
it's we make fun of them hey look at
jelly
whatever their sayings are it's like
that's what i just i mean like those
girls it's insane because they make out
when they hang out with all these guys
right isn't that weird yeah they and the
big controversy i'm waiting to see if it
happens this time but typically the big
controversy happens at the end because
there's the fantasy suites
and a lot of people get to the end and
then they decide well i can't be with
somebody who's going to go into a
fantasy suite and sleep with like three
guys at the end like i need to be the
only one guys will say that girls will
say it but i'm like you you knew you
signed up for this show you know this
fantasy suites you know they're going to
be testing the waters with everybody so
you can't tell me you didn't know that
going in i feel like they got to say
that like i if that were me
and let me tell you that would be me
like i would be like i can't sleep with
you if you slept with somebody else
and i also wouldn't go on the show yeah
i was just international if you were
so think about it yeah
good-looking girl they approach you
you're in l.a they're like we want you
to be on on this show you 100 which is
like i can't my mom wanted me to do it
when i was younger
i would kill myself my mom was like i'm
going to sign you up i'm going to sign
you up but i was like i'm not going to
be good on this show because i'm not i'm
not like crazy diva i'm not going to
fight with everybody and also i'm not
going to sleep with anybody that would
be holding the first one
out with you and then you're going to
stick your tongue down everybody else's
throat that's nasty to me i would pay to
watch you on that show i'd be like just
here in the other room like get the [ __ ]
off of me my friend reminded me the
other day because we've been talking
about all this dating stuff and i've
been talking about not that i was a
prude i mean i had pre-marital sex i
slept with people before i got married
but i was very selective um i had to be
in love or in deep like but she says to
me do you remember when we were in the
sixth grade i had never you know kissed
anybody and we went to a party and this
guy never forget his name was bobby
bobby if you're watching i'm sorry but
he leaned in to give me a kiss and i
went like this all the way out and my
friends were like jed and i was like i'm
not ready
i'm not ready for that that's great i
wasn't playing do you know i didn't like
make out with somebody i'm gonna tell
you this you're all going to think i'm
crazy when i tell you this but i did not
full-on make out somebody until i was
like 18 years old shut up
really not kidding i was very like wow i
know i didn't like it vinnie's like i
can't say the same no what do you mean i
was i remember
i remember the girl her name was mahdi
sol because i'm from the east coast the
tallest puerto rican girl ever i was
tippy when i tell you tippy toeing like
and it was like a french kiss it was
just all tongue i had no idea i hope you
don't kiss like that no no no no no no
but yo but i'm trying right now i
i remember the moment and i was
i was mad short when i was a kid i mean
i'm five eight i'm not i'm not tall she
was so huge marisol i remember her name
when i tell you tipiton hanging on stuff
just to make and it was just weird crazy
and that just set the tone for me it's a
different time if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
you